welcome folks thanks for joining the
session protect your containerized
applications with backup for gke and
anthox
we'll start with looking at history of
storage evolution in kubernetes
get a deep dive into new kubernetes
backup service for gk workloads
we also have with us broadcom team who
will share that experience using the
backup for gke service
before we get into details let's start
with a quick round of introductions
my name is manuel basra i am product
manager with google cloud and i own
container native storage and data
management services
upper house you want to go ahead and
introduce yourself
hi folks my name is apparel chitikala
currently i am working as a sas platform
delivery engineer at broadcom
thanks uh
for the introduction
now let's look at the evolution of
storage in kubernetes
we have seen terrific customer adoption
of gke for all types of workloads
this includes stateful workloads like
databases that were uncommon in the
earlier waves of kubernetes adoption
with enhancements in kubernetes storage
support customers are more comfortable
deploying data intensive workloads like
databases inside containers
the net result is that
gke customers are managing far more
critical data inside containers than
ever before
but many cloud customers are still held
back from greater adoption by their
service level objectives and backup
requirements
additionally we have heard from
customers in more regulated verticals
like finance
payments manufacturing and aerospace
that have strict data backup and
lifecycle management requirements
these customers are often
blocked from expanding their use of gke
to include production critical stateful
workloads
our goal is to unblock traditional
enterprise customers from running more
stateful workloads
with more regulated data inside gk
customers and meet their backup and dr
service levels
with that objective in mind we're
introducing a new google service called
backup for gke
backup for gke is an easy cloud-native
way for customers running workloads on
gke to protect manage and restore their
containerized applications and data
let's get into more details into what
really is backup for gke and a bit more
of an architecture the service operates
at three different layers the bottom
most layer is the data layer where we
take a copy of the data today we do
support persistent disk which is
google cloud's block storage
in future we'll also be supporting
additional types of storage
including file and other elements
so the first part is we take a copy of
the data and store it as a part of the
backup
second is
we as a part of the backup we also take
kubernetes objects and this is where a
user can define the scope of a backup a
user can define backup to be an entire
cluster
a specific namespace within a cluster or
a setup namespaces or a user can define
a lot more grammar control and scope of
backup called applications and i'll talk
more about applications in the following
slides
but once the user defines the scope of
backup we pick up all the kubernetes
configurations and objects
depending on the scope of the backup
we also
orchestrate backup within an application
and this is to support app consistent
backups a lot of applications are crash
consistent but some applications like to
flush their
memory or do qsing and i'm qsync pre and
post backup to be able to accommodate
such applications there where
there is a flexibility to create
application profiles which enable user
to inject scripts at part level for qsm
or other
application level orchestration
so as i touched backup essentially
includes two different elements one is
kubernetes objects and second is the
volume backup which is the persistent
disk data that we back up as a part of
the
backup itself
now
as a part of backup there are multiple
options
as a user you can choose where the
backup is stored so you can choose if
there are data residency requirements
you can specify which region you want
the backups to be stored
you also have ability to select and skip
certain resources if you're managing
secrets outside you can tell the backup
service to skip and not backup secrets
as a part of the backup package
same thing you can also decide not to
backup volumes if there are other ways
you're backing up data or it's more for
transient data that you don't want to
backup
another feature which is very critical
to protect against ransomware and
malicious deletions is timelock
the service allows you to timelock
backups which will disable any automated
or manual deletion of a backup unless
the time lock expires
this is really critical feature in case
somebody there is a
ransomware attack or a malicious
somebody tries to delete those backups
with a malicious intent and of course
all data is encrypted by default
getting more into details about
protected application so i touched upon
a user can define the scope of backup a
user can define a cluster as a scope of
backup a set of name spaces
or depending on
the scope of backup user can define a
specific application
and an application can correspond to
something like a mysql or a redis data
or a postgres database itself and this
allows users to execute qsing and unqsn
commands pre and post backup
we also support more complex definitions
of application like an hr data
processing application which could be a
combination of a messaging bus a
database and a web services engine
the system allows you to group all those
applications into protected application
group and the or the backup orchestrates
knowing that a particular application is
part of a larger component and
orchestrates the backup with that
knowledge in mind
so essentially as a part of the backup
you can define a cluster a namespace or
an application or application group as a
scope of the back
backups are fun recoveries are better
this is where the tool provides multiple
use cases to restore
the data you can backup a cluster
restore the cluster in into a new
cluster or into a new region
the system also allows you to backup a
cluster and restore a specific name
space or an application this can be done
in case there was an accidental deletion
of specific data set or an upgrade
failed and you want to restore the data
in its previous healthy state
the system also allows you to clone and
scale workloads in different regions so
all these are multiple use cases that
are stored that can be supported via the
backup and the recovery workflows
getting into a bit more details of
restore options
as a part of the restore the system also
allows users to change certain
parameters before the backup is restored
this may include changing storage
classes or replica accounts an example
could be you backup production
environment which was running pd ssds
but for test and dev you are using pd
standard so this is where before you
restore you can change storage classes
to map to the new environment that
you're being that you are restoring
another use case is sub scope restores
where you can always back up an entire
cluster but at the time of restore you
can decide what is the scope of restore
you may restore only one namespace or a
set of namespace or one application out
of the entire backup
another feature that was added to the
service is for delegated admin and this
use case is more around when let's say a
cluster backup executes at midnight but
as an app admin uh you may want to take
a an ad hoc backup at 4 pm just before a
critical upgrade is kicking in so this
allows cluster admins to delegate
certain authority to application admins
uh to execute an ad hoc backup just
before critical upgrades or critical
changes that are about to make you an
application namespace or a cluster
backup for gke experience is completely
integrated into gke so as you log into
your gke framework you'll be able to see
backup and restore in the left
navigation
once you get in there you'll be able to
see all the backup policies all the
clusters that are protected with the
backup policies uh when was the last
backup executed and what was the
duration of the backup the whole
interface also allows you to create new
backup plans restore plans the intent
being it's a completely seamless
workflow as you operate your workloads
in gke
now i'll pass to aquarau to talk more
about
broadcom's experience using backup for
gke service
thanks manu
so i'm part of broad company so my team
is sas platform so
this saying this cloud it shows as the
platform so in the platform we have
different components those are
infrastructure monitoring kubernetes
networking identity and access
management
while using this platform
different products teams will deploy
their applications
so broadcom software uses a foundational
sas platform architecture to manage
multiple environments across regions and
life cycle stages
the core functional uses terraform
modules to describe the infrastructure
networking and kubernetes cluster used
to support sas products being delivered
to the customers
the environment span across development
verify and production and spread across
multiple regions
by using flexible modules we can create
clusters to various sizes while
maintaining consistency across
environments
yeah this is uh it will give you more
details about host projects and shared
vpc all our service projects are
connected with the shared vpc project
and will communicate each other
applications
so the sas platform foundation takes
advantage of a cross-project
communication using google's shared vpc
this enable separation between the gk
projects and product specific projects
are project for db servers
that have not yet been migrated to gke
yeah this is slide talk about state of
state full applications
so as with most of enterprise companies
we started our kubernetes journey with
deploying stateless applications
this helped us take advantage of the gke
scale and cost optimization
moving to gkv gke improved our
development velocity besides helping
with optimizing cost
but the split architecture created some
additional challenges as our application
components were split between vms and
containers
because they are stateful applications
it takes a lot of additional data
management
services in the platform to trust it
with data especially databases
moderating applications during the
migration by moving the operators based
versions
allows us to add operational flexibility
we had stateful applications on vms and
stateless applications on gke creating
application complexity
in order to simplify the operational
environment we started exploring moving
stateful applications to gke as well
so we'll continue so uh this stateful
applications today we have
about 150 stateful workloads deployed in
gke
this helped us streamline operations and
remove a lot of functional causes by
non-uniform environment
but a few challenges remind likely
ability to achieve backup and disaster
recovery service level
we moved some workloads to gke but with
very fragment backup solutions
the fragment backup solutions made it
made difficult to maintain consistency
and created operational challenges
key requirements for critical stateful
applications
some of the use cases that will have for
key stateful workloads are ability to
achieve critical backup and disaster
recovery service levels
ability to recover an application
to non-healthy state in the event of
fault corruption fault or corruption
other use cases include ability to
quickly scale and migrate applications
backup for gke provides us with an
integrated backup and recovery platform
to achieve these critical use cases
enabling us to migrate additional
workloads to gke
key highlights from gka backup we were
particularly impressed with simplicity
of taking cluster backups and ability to
implement standard backup policies
across our enterprise workloads
backup for gke also supports application
consistent backups besides crash
consistent backup this enables us to
break any soils or backups across our
organization
ability to take incremental backup helps
us optimized cost without compromising
critical service levels
so our experience on backup for gke
service after good introduced us to the
new offering backup for gke it unblock a
lot of critical stateful workloads to
move gke
before backup for we are using
storage backup directly it made very
difficult to adhere to service level
projects
we are using backup for gk service and
will integrate it part of our core
platform services
this will enable us to standardize our
backup and disaster recovery policies
for the entire kubernetes application
fleet
thanks so i'll hand it back to you manu
to continue the session
thank you so much for walking through
the use case and how uh broadcom is
leveraging backup for gk to unlock
additional stateful workloads uh and
deploy them on gke
uh to recap folks backup for gke is an
easy cloud native way for customers
running workloads on gke to protect
manage and restore their containerized
applications and data
please reach out to your google cloud
contact to get more information on
backup for gk
and please let us know if there are any
other details we can provide thank you
again so much for
taking time to look at our session today
and would love to get your feedback
thank you all
you